now we all know the elites here have
always held up europe as a model for the
way things should be here in the united
states
so their entire understanding of the
region is based on boondoggle
conferences they attended in vienna or
fond memories of their junior years
abroad in paris
i'm not going to read your novel but
i'll tell you what i'll do
yes
i'll bring it to gertrude steins she's
the only one i trust with my writing
you'll show my novel to gertrude stein
give it to me uh uh i'll bring it to you
and she gets back from spain tomorrow
great i'm i'm gonna go get it i i'm
gonna i i can't tell you how excited i
am this is giving me such a lift that my
my heart is just racing right now okay
but but no what about what okay i'm
gonna get it and then i'll be back
paris is so exciting well they're always
jealous of europe's high gas prices they
marvel that it's guaranteed multi-week
vacation time free government health
care
and they came to love europe's
persistent anti-americanism its growing
hostility to christianity even its
refugees from north africa and the
middle east
liberal journalists fawned over the
always brilliant angela merkel in
germany
if only we could have a leader like her
people in europe are starting to talk
about angela merkel as the leader of the
free world at the moment that america
has ceded that position when europeans
talk about the leader of the free world
now they talk about angela merkel not
donald trump she is the most important
leader
in the free world right now in my uh
estimation
well that's a good clue that it's not
worked out so well for germany the
germany she left behind is not looking
so hot today is it because we see the
stark truth
europe in many ways is collapsing its
leaders are giving up it's a total
basket case
life for normal working people there is
increasingly miserable
there's also people who already live on
social security
who have then also taken the step of
getting additional food at the food bank
all of these price increases are paid
for by us the small medium business
owners
[Music]
you try to not turn on the air
conditioning to take the car less but
still there is anxiety because you have
to think about doing things that were
normal
before so sad let's review what's
happened there in just one month
today ten years after he was considered
the savior of italy's currency prime
minister mario draghi resigned and
parliament dissolved
now to france where the country there is
a total mess with emmanuel macron split
government once ridiculed by the elites
marine le pen's national uh front party
national rally party is no longer fringe
it received nearly 42 percent of the
vote last april
and last month the party got 89 seats in
parliament up from eight
of course the uk's bojo boris johnson
who didn't govern as a populist is a
fake populist he was forced out and
yesterday made his final appearance
before parliament
mission largely accomplished
for now
hasta la vista baby
well brexit was accomplished but i'm
sure you wanted that to happen
and now the euro well that's in the
toilet it's actually in parity with the
u.s dollar
and we know europe is completely hapless
it's almost given up vis-a-vis china
they're not strong or principled enough
to resist any of china's aggressive
economic news and moves don't hold your
breath there
europe's energy policy that's in tatters
because we know that they're run by the
grainiacs which is killing them
and as we approach cold weather months
they're essentially going to be begging
vladimir putin for whatever gas he's
going to send down that nordstrom one
pipeline
so energy rationing you heard it in
those clips we played earlier is being
seriously discussed across the eu
in fact it just unveiled a new gas
rationing plan this week urging all 27
member states to reduce gas demand by 15
from august through march
how to use less energy is the new
european battle cry
so we're all supposed to be happy today
that i guess russia reopened nordstrom
one
but we find out it's still not operating
at full capacity or even half capacity
so russia is able to play games with a
europe that is not strong enough to
defend itself against russian aggression
now remember how the establishment here
derided trump when he went over to
europe and he told the european leaders
that they had to become militarily
stronger they had to spend more money on
their own military
diplomats dumbfounded by president
trump's barrage of attacks on nato
allies president trump criticizing our
nato allies attacking uh the eu the
trump administration has undermined nato
trump has consistently attacked our
allies great and small
first of all let's remember that
under the nato agreement they're
supposed to spend two percent of their
gdp on their militaries
okay pretty much no one's doing that
that's all trump asked them to do
and of course who can forget the
reaction of the european leaders when
trump demanded they begin to fulfill all
those nato commitments well even with
all of their problems here our economy
is still stronger it's still more
resilient than europe's
now in 2021 our gdp was about 23
trillion or so
the gdp for the entire eu which has
again 27 member states
was just over 17 trillion dollars and
remember this is important they have
more than 100 million more people than
we have here
in our military it's far bigger and
stronger than all of the european unions
combined
and we we say thank you to the u.s
taxpayers for that we're still carrying
the europeans on our backs decades and
decades after world war ii
but remember the left here is working
overtime to dismantle both our economy
and our military as the angle
demonstrated this week
they don't want us to be stronger than
europe they want us to be as weak as
europe and essentially fold it into that
idiotic rules-based international order
now we should learn the hard lesson here
americans are not going to be saved by
europe
or the liberal world order
china doesn't give a rats you know what
about tony blinken's rules-based
international order in europe
europe can't save itself
so we are going to have to save
ourselves
and that's the angle hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else